[Music]
uh we have time for one question oh
okay
monogamy the board
game but you can have as many houses as
you want on Park Place yeah well as you
know being a standup comic I travel
around all the time so uh I I don't have
a steady lady I just go out and enjoy
myself just ask out my makeup artist my
life Live It Up do you want to get
married and do the no it just ends it
ends in divorce at
22 28 I got married when I was 22 oh
okay I wasn't
listening neither was I enough
apparently but you never want to you
know Mrs Benson
um if it you know if it comes together
if it if it happens but I've gone so far
with without
it that I'm kind of like why why not
finish this
race why not go all the way to the end
just me doing my thing you know I'm not
like asexual or anything I'll you know
I'll make
love when the when the opportunity
presents
itself I don't know of women you know
what I say after every time I make love
Yeah wash my damn
ta
[Music]
a